he's in the sentence for national league
cy young award a goal that he has openly
said i want to win the award i look at
the other pitchers that are in the race
he can perhaps make two starts tonight
and maybe on sunday on short rest as
well offering from bauer
there goes the runner throw down to
second base
not in time
he's probably assuming that garcia's not
going to run and
that's going to be a review call right
there because that was a lot closer than
it looked
at first
out
strike three call
wind up in the o2 swing and a miss back
to back punch out for bauer julian
hauser yeah one in five that one win
came on the road in chicago against the
chicago white sox that was back on
august 5th i think bottom's gonna have a
good night he is overdue against the
brewers oh for 22 against milwaukee and
he swings and sends a fly ball deep left
center field way back there and gone
going to time that up any better could
you
a two-run blast for vato and the reds
are on top two to nothing
vato's 11th home run of the season
and his first hit of 2020 against the
brewers is a big one i just don't think
there's a team in baseball that can shut
down bottle for the entire year
balls and two strikes
struck him out
barrows got such good command of his
breaking pitches that's a slider i think
there for
and he just be able to he's able to
feather that right off the outside edge
yeah one two again
see you later
[Applause]
jesse winker strolling to the plate
friends with a two-nothing lead winker
against adrian hauser in the fourth
right field down the line
and out of here
[Music]
solo home run for winker is 12 3 nothing
reds
finally got a breaking ball it was a
hangar inner third of the plate about
thigh high
yeah whiskers all over that the only
question was you're going to stay high
enough to get out of here
there's aquino how about that bare
hander from adrian hauser
risky business there he gets the first
out of the inning
if he doesn't do that that's probably a
hit
not hit very hard
not like the one winker hit check this
out that might be a hit against by
hauser
howard loads up for the one-two pitch
and there's a drive deep left field stay
fair it will be a
what is it gone
well foul ball okay and
no another ball no help anywhere monitor
ball i'm looking at all these monitors
we have here is anybody doing anything
yeah
i was going off bauer's body language
there that
so again a 1-2
and that strike three call
can you talk about a turn of events yeah
let me give you that so now vogel back
in scoring position for orlando arcia
has the what he wants
and the one one to arcia and that's hit
well into the left center field gap
aquino won't get to it it's over his
head and gonna bounce up against the
wall vogel backs around thirty is gonna
score
and orlando arcia with an rbi double
gets the brewers on the board here in
the top of the fifth
it's a 3-1 ball game
orlando drives in his 18th of the cut of
the season
and that lead-off walk comes around to
score
the reds have two on with one out and
now claudio will deal with a
right-handed hitter and eugenio suarez
in the air left field going back is
yellidge and kiss it goodbye
third home run of the game for the reds
this one a three-run shot
the sweet swing of suarez
i think spoilers saw enough pitches in
this at bat to kind of get him
used to a slower offering look at him
reach out there stay back just enough to
be able to reach out and hook that ball
down the left field line and get it out
of here
[Applause]
seven strikeouts for bauer
struck him out
i mean wouldn't you be fired up if you
could do this
lay that breaking ball out there look
how far jurko is from home plate he
wants that ball somewhere way more
inside
swag at a miss he struck him out
how about trevor balor first and third
nobody out
three
straight
punch outs
how about that effort by trevor bauer
and he and vogelback trade work
tonight and worry about sunday later i
get it
11 strikeouts from bauer
gets away from barnhart he will attack
and how about trevor bauer
eight innings of one run baseball
on the most crucial game of the season
on the ground suarez second on to first
base
that's a double play and that'll do it
[Applause]
the reds win their fourth straight
series